what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime uproar and I'm back at it
again to discuss the latest insane
chapter of one piece a quick side note
to say that I'm filling in for our boy
goes in this week as unfortunately he is
ill make sure to send him some love and
headparts in the comment section below
I'm sure he'll really appreciate that
and I'll do my best to carry the torch
for this week's chapter a chapter that
exploded dropping a very interesting and
unexpected bombshell at the end so make
sure to stay tuned for that now if you
do enjoy these one piece videos on the
channel you know what to do smash that
like button if you haven't already make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one piece chapter reviews and
updates and now without further Ado
let's jump into It spoilers and all
first of all I'd just like to draw
attention to the beautifully colored
illustration in promotion of the new
one-piece film red where we have a load
of our favorite characters Shanks looks
boss as always Luffy's gear 5 looking
sick as ever and we of course have our
beloved straw hats and a bunch of other
characters now I'm a bit of a Nami
Fanboy so my eyes would definitely drawn
to that bum corner you love to see it
now on to the chapter chapter 1065 was
entitled the six faces of vegapunk which
as we all know from chapter 1062 is the
six satellites that vagapunk had split
himself into and we are certainly going
to see some of them in this one we start
off on Lab stratum Egghead the island of
the future with Zorro and Brooke who had
stayed on the ship because they did not
trust Lilith the evil vagapunk Zorro
says the way I see it when it comes to a
government Island you gotta think about
who's gonna be around to bail them out
if they get caught of course the straw
hats have been in this situation many a
Time time where they have been split
apart and have had to rescue one another
now the really funny thing for me is
just how normal this situation is for
them and the relaxed and carefree
approach they take to it Brooke simply
says yeah I was thinking the same thing
would you care for some tea I just think
that's amazing it's just like meh it's
okay they can take care of themselves if
they do need us we'll just chill until
then with some tea there's there's no
need no need for us to stress out about
it they can handle themselves we then
see Caribou if you remember he snuck
onto the ship in A Barrel in chapter 10
60 when the crew were leaving wano we
saw him fall out of said Barrel in
chapter 1061 in the situation involving
Vega force and now he's revealing
himself to Zorro and Brooke he says in a
very timid manner excuse me sirs to
which Zoro is like bro you still here so
brutal Caribou says that the deal was to
drop him off anywhere away from wano but
he didn't think that they'd be heading
for a government Island Again Zorro
replies in a stoic brutal fashion by
saying I heard you helped our captain
out appreciate it see you around again
so cold so which we see those tears
streaming down caribou's faces he's like
you jerks I'll remember this the
question is will this guy have a part to
play in this Arc seems interesting so we
will definitely have to keep an eye out
for any development there we then move
on to Nami usop Frankie Sanji and Robin
who are all with Lilith Nami and usop
are awestruck by the lab and the new
stairs that are sprouting out of the
ground Frankie asks Lilith what kind of
setup is it that they have here how is
it powered to which she responds by
saying that you could say that the whole
island is run on fire Frankie asks
doesn't that burn through a load of
Natural Resources to which Lilith says
that she is always looking into
alternative fuels and if there was such
thing as an eternal flame like the sun
Lilith would like to make her very own
sun and this got me thinking about Luffy
who of course had recently attained his
son God Nica mode do you think he will
have anything to do with Lilith's plan
on making her own son there is more
evidence that could point to this
possibility later in the chapter so keep
that thought in mind for now we of
course also have Sanji and Sabo as
contenders for fueling this energy but
like I said we'll come back to this so
for now we see more of this Island's
fascinating technology as Lilith
straight up passes through a wall or the
closed main gate as we see in the next
panel the guys are knocking on the door
asking her to open up to which she tells
them to never let their own senses dupe
them and just to pass through this
really gave me those platform nine and
three quarter feels from like the Harry
Potter franchise we then see sanji's
head poke through the wall and it's such
a perfect panel man his his blank
expression just had me in stitches I
don't know why but it just worked and I
I'm all for it anyway the guys managed
to pass through the wall with ease to
which usop turns around and bangs on the
closed gate in shock saying that it has
turned back to metal again does this
ability to pass through certain walls
have something to do with the futuristic
clothes that they are wearing now they
do have other functions as we will see
later on in the chapter and we have
already seen through Luffy and Bonnie as
they said the clothes make them feel as
light as a feather so we will have to
keep an eye on that one for sure on our
way to see a vegapunk Addison the third
Vega Punk representing Flair we have a
funny little panel where Nami is saying
that they should look for futuristic
treasure with her classic grin and shiny
eyes usop then asks her what she thinks
this future treasure looks like to which
she responds by saying that it could be
like a flower made out of Exquisite
antique gems usop of course remains
unimpressed as he states that he can't
tell if her taste is closer to that of a
little girl or an old hag Nami then hits
our boy with a future kick in the next
panel and I really appreciate the little
bit of humor thrown in there it's great
in that same panel we see the rest of
the guys shocked by the presence of a
certain individual that certain
individual to them is jinbei however
something is not quite right this jimbei
is sat in front of a huge tank that says
Sarah of him IV Robin says that she
doesn't think it's him as he looks a
little too young and the rest of the
crew debate on three different
possibilities usop takes a guess that it
could be his son Nami thinks that maybe
jimbei has turned into a kid whereas
Sanji thinks it is just a coincidence
and that the kid not only has wings but
also an ominous Heir about him now I'm
sure you like me thought pass a fist or
as soon as she saw him right Frankie in
a panic State confirms our thoughts by
saying that there is a fourth
possibility and that he has a bad
feeling about it the fourth possibility
being that he is a pacifista the chapter
then explodes into some classic one
piece action as the seraphim jimbei
unleashes a ferocious laser beam attack
sending our straw hats flying usop of
course goes into his obvious panic mode
and screams that this was all a giant
trap and that they should have known
that the government were never going to
roll out the red car carpet for them
Nami however Springs into action herself
and goes on the offensive she says does
this mean that they are trying to clone
jimbe into some sort of soldier for
themselves she goes on to say that he's
still a kid and doesn't want to fight
him however needs must and she goes on
to attack which sends him flying back
now it was here that we noticed
something interesting as the seraphim
jimbei is splashing around in the water
everyone is shocked as usop shouts out
he's got devil fruit Powers Nami asks
what's going on and we see that Zeus
replies to her through her baton asking
if he should pop out to which she says
no Frankie also in a panic State shouts
out that he knows that ability anyway
out of nowhere the seraphim jimbei
lunges forward and grabs our girl Nami
by the throw to which not cool man no
one no one harms our girl I like I
mentioned at the start of the video that
I am rather partial to NAMI so I took
this throat grabbing a bit personally
but you know who also took this
personally
oh yeah
Sanji the next page was a truly epic one
in my personal opinion as we see the
burning rage in sanji's eyes as he
announces that the seraphim jimbei has
just signed his own death warrant by
grabbing our beloved Nami by the throat
he continues to say that he doesn't care
if he is the real jimbei or not and
unleashes his Fury in a very powerful
very epic kick which sends him flying
freeing Nami from his clutches just a
super powerful panel there for me and
you just love to see Sanji jumping into
the rescue of Nami great stuff truly now
the rest of the straw hats also go on
the offensive to protect one another
with Robin saying that she thinks it is
also unforgivable what he has just done
before attacking back with the insane
sea serpent Snap Dragon spank knocking
the seraphim jimbei back however it is
not enough to keep him down as he then
turns his attention to Robin and usop
then steps up to the bat after telling
Robin to get out of there with his
slingshot armed and ready he notices
that jimbei can also use fish man karate
he then fires a lethal green star skull
exploding grass connecting with the head
of his Target usob goes on to say that
he knows that this isn't the real jinbei
but it feels messed up the Smoke Clears
and then jimbei is gone completely
vanished only to sneak up behind usop
and grab him Sanji frantically goes in
to save USA but is stopped by Frankie
who says that he has got this he tells
usop not to move a muscle as he fires
off an insane radical beam now
interestingly of all the attacks the
seraphim jimbei has just faced is
Frankie's radical beam that Edison
commands him to dodge and watch out for
the laser beam attack this attack of
Frankie's really caught the attention of
Edison and has most certainly piqued his
interest
Edison says he just used a beam who in
tarnation is this guy and man gotta say
it's a great moment for our boy Frankie
that's for sure this is now where we get
to see Edison properly for the first
time and I gotta say I like his design
here he's this small robot with what
looks like a jet pack on his back maybe
and his head is shaped like that of a
football I like him it's cool he goes on
to say that it's getting risky out there
this jimbei seraphim is still just a kid
and that he wasn't meant to be put
through laser tests until later Lilith
is furious and agrees with Addison as
she says do they have the faintest idea
how much one seraphim costs continuing
to go full evil mode she threatens to
rip Frankie's skull off to which we see
Addison say don't you think that's a
little bit too evil now I liked that
little dynamic between them there as he
seemingly tried to call her anger in a
way that he had to be careful of what he
said himself now it is in that moment
that Edison has a spark of Genius as he
claims to have just come up with a new
invention he rushes off to work on this
idea where he leaves the rest to the
next vagapunk that we are meeting for
the first time Pythagoras the punk who
represents wisdom this guy is a larger
robot who seems to love data as he says
you don't come across battle data this
Rich every day this is a once in a
lifetime opportunity we then move on to
see Edison working away on his idea as
he commands the next vagapunk York to
eat something for him she is seen
sitting on a giant cushion as a bunch of
minions are bringing her loads of food
for her to eat we are even told that her
BMI is over 600 which is just crazy now
it's a really interesting concept here
to see how these different vegapunks
work we obviously have Edison who is
this crazy genius who comes up with a
million ideas a second Pythagoras is the
one who inputs all the data Lilith is
well evil Atlas is a bit of a brawler
from the looks of things Shaka is off
talking with dragon and York looks to be
the glutton of the bunch the one who
eats for all of the other Vega punks as
they are too busy dealing with their own
things so we go back to Pythagoras who
is analyzing all of the combat data and
points out that the seraphim's attack
patterns have continued to develop as it
grows He suggests that they try and
accelerate their growth though that will
come with its own obstacles and then
mentions the green blood concentration
has risen so I do wonder what this green
blood is and what its significance will
be to State the color of the blood does
suggest to me that it will be of some
importance but that's all we've got for
now and we find out that York has
another function for the Vagabonds not
only does she consume food for them but
also disposes of it too if you get get
what I'm saying here Edison says he
really needs the toilet but he is far
too busy to go which we then see York
coming out of the bathroom this in its
own way is the interesting thing here as
firstly we see that Edison and
Pythagoras say that that hit the spot
referring to I guess the intake and drop
off of food from York and secondly that
York is completely thin down here and we
are properly introduced to her as York
the vegapunk of Desire now I may be a
bit degenerate and biased here but I
really like what I see from York in this
panel appearance wise anyway as we are
told that she is on her fourth sdn cycle
of the day which we are kindly told
stands for snack dump nap I don't know
about you but I personally would say
that out of all the vagapunks York is
most certainly living the dream right
here and anyway back to the Face-Off
with the seraphim Jim Bay and the fight
is interrupted and put to a halt none
other than Shaka has appeared before
them all Lilith is not at all pleased
that the fight has been stopped as she
says of course that scoundrel butts in
when things finally get good Shaka
introduces himself to the straw hearts
and we find out that the boots that they
are all wearing are stuck to the floor
via gravity and magnetic so that they
can't make a move on him Shaka says that
these boots can be magnetically disabled
at any point while in the lab so this is
going back to them walking through the
gate earlier in the chapter we yet again
see another functionality of these
futuristic clothes which led me to
believe that it was these clothes that
allowed them to pass through the closed
game do you think that's the case let us
know in the comments and do you think
there'll be more functions to these
futuristic clothes I'm sure we're gonna
find out more as this all continues so
back to the conversation Rob says to
shocker so you're saying resistance is
futile then to which shocker responds by
saying I know better than to let my
guard down around Pirates this suggests
to us that he has had many are dealing
with pirates before of course he's
talking to dragon and whatnot but like
it's interesting I'm sure there's a bit
of bit of History to this guy usop is
totally confused here with all of the
different vagapongs that they have just
met I absolutely love his sarcasm here
as usop's like oh yeah did I forget to
mention
um yeah I'm a vegapunk too it was just
absolutely hilarious and his face while
he was saying this too was just perfect
I I love absolutely love these little
loose up moments Frankie tells usop to
cut it out before Shaka says something
very very interesting which leads to the
big twist of the chapter he asks do you
think this island looks like the future
now Frankie goes into hyper Fanboy mode
just like I would in an anime figure
shop as he lists off all the things that
he has seen and loved about the Island's
technology he just wants to see more and
in a very excited manner just straight
out asks shucker to take him on a full
tour of the place so that he can see all
the goodies that they are cooking up
Shaka Khana shrugs this off and
continues with what he's saying he's
like it's actually quite the contrary
this is an island of the past it then
perfectly cuts to Luffy Bonnie Chopper
and jimbeus they are all in awe of a
certain site Luffy says check it out
Chopper you can tell because it's all
rusted and stuff as they remain shocked
at what they see we quickly cut back to
Shaka and Frankie as he asks what do you
mean by the past Shaka says what if I
were to tell you that long ago there was
once a highly Advanced Kingdom not
unlike Egghead when it comes to
technology a civilization from 900 years
ago would you believe me now in this
panel we see a huge old rusted Mecca
Golem looking thing and I've got to say
this thing looks absolutely incredible
truly does and of course in true classic
Luffy fashion he's all like I want to
ride it obviously obviously that is
Luffy's reaction but yeah this this girl
man it looks absolutely absolutely
insane I'm very intrigued on it to
finish the chapter the narrator asks us
what was the world like back then and
that's the question isn't it what a very
interesting and intriguing twist right
at the end of the chapter I really love
the futuristic vibe that this new arc
has had to it so far but by throwing in
the ancient civilization aspect of 900
years ago in there it's just ramped this
one up to another level not only has it
ramped things up a bit but it also
brought a lot of questions to the table
you know what was this technology like
back then does it tie into the ancient
Kingdom what happened during all that
time the reveal made me think back to
that link to Luffy fee and his son God
Nica Powers with you know Lilith's
desire to make her own son that I
touched on earlier was this ancient
Kingdom once fueled by Joy boy who also
had the son God Nica Powers was he once
their son an energy resource that has
since lied dormant in all that time
until now Luffy is on that same island
that was just my first thought on it but
certainly let us know your theories in
the comments section below as well as
your thoughts on all the Vega punks that
we've met in this crazy and insane
chapter if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more one piece reviews
and chapters don't forget to smash that
like button make this the video you
subscribe if you haven't and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece chapter reviews and updates
until the next chapter or video drops
feel free to check out our huge and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos on all seven yonko Admirals an
hour-long video on Shanks and more link
to that is in the video description and
on screen now thanks again for having me
this week in gozen's absence and we
can't wait to see you in the next one
till next time my friends take care
peace